there will be four locations including
Sky Canyon where this new wrong way
radar technology will be installed other
locations are Durango Drive in Kyle
Canyon both along 95 plus Star Avenue on
Interstate 15. according to the Nevada
Department of Transportation these areas
were chosen because they already have
the infrastructure in place for the
system the way it works is a series of
flashing lights will go off once the
radar detects a driver going the wrong
way a short video of the driver will be
recorded and then sent to First
Responders drivers stopping for gas on
Sky Canyon applauded the system I mean
overall it's it's probably a good
indicator if if that helps somebody turn
around and prevent them from going down
the wrong way putting other people's
lives in danger I guess I have
personally went the wrong way a couple
of times so it got real confusion I've
been in this area for 20 years and I
personally made that mistake anything
that saves lives I'm all for it this
technology is already being used in
Northern Nevada and our multi-year study
shows nearly 80 percent of drivers
turned around before reaching their
freeway when the lights went off one
driver says people need to take
responsibility for their driving don't
do nothing wrong don't drink and drive
Governor Steve sislock says the
installation of this new technology will
employ nearly 1500 people across the
state reporting along Sky Canyon Joshua
peguero eight news now now in addition
to here in Las Vegas this new wrong way
driver detection will also be installed
in Carson City